قبل ستة أيام
سعى فلاديمير بوتين الروسي إلى
زعزعة أسس العالم الحر
معتقدًا أنه يمكن أن يجعله
ينحني لطرقه المهددة ،
لكنه أخطأ في تقديره
لأنه اعتقد أنه يمكن أن يتدحرج إلى أوكرانيا
وأن العالم سوف يتدحرج
بدلاً من ذلك
التقى بمركز تجاري  جدار القوة
لم يتوقعه أو يتخيله أبدًا أنه التقى
بالشعب الأوكراني
والرئيس
زلينسكي لكل أوكراني خوفهم
شجاعتهم تصميمهم
يلهم حرفيًا المجموعات العالمية
من المواطنين الذين يصدون الدبابات
بأجسادهم ،
كل من الطلاب إلى المتقاعدين إلى
المعلمين الذين تحولوا إلى جنود يدافعون عن وطنهم
و  في هذا الصراع ، قال الرئيس زيلينسكي
في خطابه أمام البرلمان الأوروبي ، إن
النور سينتصر على الظلام ، أصبح
بوتين الآن معزولًا عن العالم
أكثر من أي وقت مضى
معًا
جنبًا إلى جنب مع حلفائنا ،
ونحن الآن نفرض عقوبات اقتصادية قوية
نقطعها.  من أكبر البنوك الروسية
في المالية الدولية
ystem منع البنك المركزي الروسي من
الدفاع عن
الروبل الروسي ، مما يجعل صندوق بوتين الحربي البالغ 630 مليار دولار
بلا قيمة ،
نحن نخنق وصول
روسيا ، ونخنق وصول روسيا إلى
التكنولوجيا التي
ستضعف قوتها الاقتصادية وتضعف جيشها
لسنوات قادمة
الليلة ،
أقول لـ  الأوليغارشيون
الروس والقادة الفاسدون الذين بنوا مليارات
الدولارات من هذا النظام العنيف لا
الولايات المتحدة
أعني أن
وزارة العدل في الولايات المتحدة تقوم بتشكيل
فريق عمل مخصص لملاحقة
جرائم الأوليغارشية الروسية التي
ننضم إليها  الحلفاء الأوروبيون
للعثور على اليخوت الخاصة بهم والاستيلاء عليها في شققهم الفاخرة
بطائراتهم الخاصة ،
نحن قادمون لك لتحقيق مكاسب غير مشروعة
، وأعلن الليلة أننا
سننضم إلى حلفائنا في إغلاق
المجال الجوي الأمريكي أمام جميع الرحلات الجوية الروسية مما يزيد من
عزلة روسيا وإضافة
ضغط إضافي على اقتصادهم
[موسيقى]
ليس لديه أدنى فكرة عما سيحدث ،
فقد الروبل بالفعل 30 بالمائة
منه
خسر سوق الأسهم الروسية 40 في
المائة من قيمته
وبقيت التجارة
معلقة ، والاقتصاد الروسي
يترنح وبوتين وحده هو المسؤول
مع حلفائنا ،
فنحن نقدم الدعم
للأوكرانيين في كفاحهم من أجل الحرية ،
المساعدة العسكرية الاقتصادية  المساعدة
المساعدات الإنسانية نقدم
أكثر من مليار دولار من
المساعدات المباشرة لأوكرانيا وسنواصل
مساعدة الشعب الأوكراني في الدفاع عن
وطنهم والمساعدة في تخفيف معاناتهم